hello reject nation Greg Alva here and
I'm John we haven't seen one of these
guys videos in a while but boy people
have been asking us for days to do this
we like to wait til it's not trending
anymore to keep it real all right but
real easy to get a video big while it's
trying to yeah you see how it should
have ended the movie that people still
talk to us about I just I just try to
not talk about it anymore patient the
day shaft for Craig kettle
this should be good
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
the chain of command dictates that
Admiral Ackbar will take command
because seniority this is a don't have
time to waste
rescuing courses or doing that random
kids no matter how sad it makes us I get
it geez we're waiting in the grass
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
these are your first steps parents
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what do you want
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what do you think I was trying to do
[Music]
[Music]
here we go what did you think was going
to happen and I would take on the first
order with nothing but amazing sword yes
that's exactly what I thought was going
to happen it actually does sound pretty
awesome okay let's do it
this place is dead anyway let's give
Mark Hamill hoist
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
turn around
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
- hilarious
come on done I wish to tell everyone the
plan we have our secret base on a nearby
planet that we are trying to reach
so nobody freak out or start a mutiny or
anything we actually have a plan
[Music]
Wow that was that was awesome I was
pretty damn good how it should have
ended man that's they perfectly made fun
of a lot of things that people pointed
out like where they oh this is the
opening bit when they open the door
because that is something that I think
when I saw Ingrid Jo's review he pointed
out I think I was them and and then I
heard other people point that out and
then when I saw the movie again yeah
sucked out in the vacuum of space I
don't know maybe there's some kind of
special force yeah the amazing points
things that might bid a little nitpicky
when you watch the examples here of how
things could have gone down you're like
maybe it wasn't so much of an epic but
an actual flaw even just the beginning
with Poe talking to the ship like shoot
yes because just shot up and killed him
we got rid of him this is a fun
character moment us necessarily great
strategy mode I just love that bit more
Rose is talking to Finn about look we
can't say we need random children
because horses vary over time we want a
ticking time clock right now
yes I've friends lives yeah yeah well on
the grass yeah this video is specially
they do and they kind of give you some
of the fanservice things that you wanted
there's kind of also making fun of fans
for not having their fan theories met
the way they wanted to I love what
Kenobi shows up and raise super excited
about it yeah Anakin shows how to talk
to and making fun of when Rose saves
Finn that is so true and how that plays
out because that moment always did
strike me as odd because she saves him
but she had no idea that Luke Skywalker
was gonna show up and interrupt this
whole thing she had no idea yeah well I
Finn had the chance to save everyone's
life and the cutter made Finn's
storyline more effective if he just
saved the day like - so she had no idea
any that was gonna happen but she ends
up saving Finn yeah everyone's gonna die
because you but I appreciated a lot of
how it really should have ended while
it's funny you can't help watching ago
that would have been kind of cool if it
did something along the line
that though of Luke going you know what
I'm gonna show up I'm actually gonna
handle some business right now and then
ray and Luke fight side-by-side and save
the day that would have been actually
pretty sweet to see I love what happens
the last Jedi I love the last Jedi that
would have been cool I think it would
have been a little more rewarding for
certain fans yeah for sure the things
yeah I really I've only seen at the one
time but I really enjoyed it that time I
saw it was very compelled by it as a
movie but you know the more I hear
people talk about it the more I'm just
like yeah I can see how yeah definitely
not perfect and definitely not perfect
this is just a furthering of that
experience what can I say man hizzy you
guys are freakin geniuses over better
well done
and guys shout out today for Craig
Kittel my friend we haven't talked in a
while since the only last talking like
October November remember very few
things about you and Mary from Alabama
where no one's racist so I'm glad to
know you my friend and I remember what
we talked you said that you were nervous
to start up your own channel even though
you loved talking about movies you know
what I can't think of anyone with a
hardcore southern Alabama accent who
could do movie reviews buddy so why
don't you be the first one it could be
you you could be the first major
youtuber who reviews movies in Alabama
we need that that could change our
country around even though we haven't
talked in a while you stayed pledged to
patreon this whole time and I want to
say thank you for staying here my friend
your name's Craig Kittel and what that
tells me is that your penis is not
little ha ha ha working a skittle rhyme
I don't want to I'm sure he gets that
all the time ha but it's arrived it's
still rhyme huh you're a poet and I and
you you didn't even know that you were
rhyming at the time and since Happy
Thanksgiving was the last holiday happy
Christmas and New Year's and Valentine's
Day - yeah oh dear sure those chicks in
Alabama are freaking hot blonde loud
subscribe to the rejects that
notification bell
see if